foreign
we've learned a lot over the last 13
years as the minimalist we've formed a
lot of rules in our own lives and I
thought maybe we could talk about
our five favorite minimalist rules that
we've come up with okay now 16 of them
are in our free minimalist rule book
which people can download over at the
minimalists.com it's completely free and
then we've made up a bunch of other
rules along the way on our YouTube
channel and other places that people can
check out but of all of the rules which
by the way they're not really rules
they're just boundaries they're
completely elastic they're adjustable to
your life
Ryan I'm wondering what is your favorite
of all of these lessons we've learned
over the last 13 years yeah spontaneous
combustion for sure mainly because of
how the story came about but it is such
a simple rule I mean just looking at
anything the spontaneously combusted
will I replace it it's like it just put
things into perspective really quickly I
did this in Ireland with someone who was
talking about having a storage unit and
how much they spent on it this is just
like a random person
um
and I didn't even tell them about you
know the minimalists or anything but I
was like if that's a spontaneous
spontaneously combusted how would you
feel they were like oh I feel so
relieved and they were like I needed
that I'm like yeah yeah it's a very
simple very quick to the point Rule and
that the fascinating thing about that
rule and I had it first on my list as
well because I use it all the time with
friends because
like with closets especially people go
in their closet if those clothes
spontaneously combusted would you
replace all of them well God no it would
be awful why would I do that okay why
would I hold on to them right and I
would say the same thing is true we
would talk about some heavy things today
even with our relationship Ryan yeah no
if our really if the SP if our
relationship spontaneously could busted
I would not replace it with the old
version I would replace it with this new
version yeah of our relationship yeah
and that's always what we're asking with
a rule like that is if something
spontaneous like a bust if your career
spontaneously combusted you were laid
off would you go back and get the same
exact career if so great that means
you're in the most appropriate job yeah
if the purple t-shirt I'm wearing right
now is for the special occasion of Ryan
Nicodemus celebrating Ryan Nicodemus if
it were to spontaneous like a bus well I
guess I'd replace it right now but
tomorrow I probably wouldn't replace it
because it's going to serve its purpose
today I'm not going to keep clinging to
it I think that's what that rule really
highlights any of these rules the more
you can apply them to non-physical
things that's really where the value
is with these rules yes it's sneaking
because it deals with the physical
things but it's just the start yeah man
what's your second favorite
uh 2020 rule yeah that was just that's
pretty mind-boggling
because it was just something we came up
with and I'm and it's really worked so
well yeah we call it the just in case
rule anything you hold on to just in
case you can replace for less than
twenty dollars in less than 20 minutes
from wherever you are and that has given
me permission to let go of
tens of thousands of just in case items
yeah and the cool thing is you never
have to use it I think we've invented
that rule 12 years ago and between the
two of us we've used it five times so
it's cost of what maybe a hundred bucks
who wouldn't pay a hundred dollars to
get rid of tens of thousands of items
that are just getting in the way yeah
yeah but that rule also applies to what
I'm holding on to this career just in
case
I'm holding on to this relationship
transactionally just in case
what are you holding on to just in case
that you'd feel Freer if you just let it
go yeah here's another one for you the
seasonality rule that was my third one
too how was it yeah oh wow we also
called the 90-90 rule are using this
order as well yeah oh that's great man
and so the 90-90 rule for me is like
okay have I worn this shirt in the last
90 days
will I wear it in the next 90 days and
if not I give myself permission to let
go but that seasonality rule can be
expanded to whatever it could be the one
year one year rule it you can apply it
to anything if you own a chainsaw if you
own a couch or you own a chair or you
own a blender whatever it is have I used
in the last 90 days Will I use in the
next 90 days so the answer is no to both
Let It Go but what about the seasons of
our relationships as well we were just
reading from necessary endings uh from
Dr Henry cloud and in here he talks
about the seasons a season ends so a new
season can begin guess what happens if
you don't end the season though you hold
on to something that isn't serving you
anymore something that did serve you is
now this this burden
yeah keep holding on and the seasonality
rule just tells me all right this season
for this has come
and this season is over Let's Make Way
for the new season yeah what when I was
thinking about that
uh that rule it was really about how
when we first did the packing party
and I was looking at all the clothes in
my closets and
I'm like well I do use some of these and
I think it was it would think it was
your idea where you're like well
you know I've used in the last year
you're going to use it in the next year
I'm like oh that's good like that
because it gave me permission to hold on
to way more than I should have but that
made me feel good right because I could
have went on to a bunch of stuff but it
also gave me permission to let go of so
much it was a start the one year was a
great starting point yeah and you
realize like wow maybe 90 days is more
appropriate yeah now I'm like a year is
way too much for me yeah and even for me
now I'm close to 30 days on most of my
clothes you're gonna tomorrow you're
gonna be like one day on that shirt yeah
this is getting donated immediately
after this podcast have I worn this
yesterday yes will I wear it tomorrow no
uh another rule that really stood out to
me is this one has helped me with
impulse so much the wait for it rule we
also call it the 30 30 rule it's easier
now than ever to act on impulse
it's okay to wait as well and so if I'm
this originally started because being at
the checkout line at the grocery store
I'll just grab this pack of gum or this
candy bar or whatever something that I
know intellectually is unhealthy for me
but in the moment I feel the impulse I
might as well I'm just right here yeah
yeah and so what I've done now because
purchasing is so ubiquitous one click
purchases I can get it right now I can
get it delivered same day
well in Montana it'll be the next day or
two days later but you get the point
talk about creating friction yeah and so
that's exactly what you do because you
think about like oh absolute convenience
removes all friction what happens when
you remove all friction you lose
traction when you've lost traction you
begin to Korean it's like an ice skating
ring and I don't know how to skate very
well with impulse and so what you're
learning to do by adding a little bit of
friction is you're skating with the
impulse you might want the thing 30
hours from now but if you postpone it
there's a good chance you might not want
it as well put some distance between me
and the impulse and all of a sudden oh
that thing is less enticing 30 hours
later and I think that's true with
career decisions let me sleep on it for
a night it's with relationships oh wow
why did I even get did I even think
about getting into this relationship do
I want to get into another relationship
right now maybe I'll wait for it and I
think that's where the the wait for a
rule applies to our lives outside of
material possessions oh man Professor
son Professor Sean get ready to write
this down for a minimal maximum this is
good
um absolute compulsivity
results in absolute misery yes and in
the moment it doesn't because we are
here to gratify our pleasures and that's
why it leads to misery because it's such
a
little
little ruse that we fall for yes yeah
the micro indiscretions that in the
moment don't make us miserable but they
always lead to misery if it's just yes
yes yes yes yes yes to each impulse
guess what happens we end up at this
dead end of misery and it's really hard
to turn around then at that point
and we often
swing the pendulum all the way over we
become ascetics and then we shun all
pleasure and that also can lead to
misery yeah but if we're
doing desire and pleasure intentionally
by waiting for it is this kind of
pleasure appropriate for me is this
purchase appropriate for me is this
relationship appropriate for me not a
former version of me but for this
version of me right now you know the
wait for it rule also applies to
criticism
constructive feedback and contention
it's very easy to think that if I have a
problem with what just happened the best
time to address it is when I look and
feel angry because then they will see
how much it matters to me and they will
respond to the way in which my visible
observable anger rumbles the room that's
right sometimes it sends a really
powerful signal when you can say
I'm gonna wait
I'm gonna give this 24 hours because I
want to process what I feel I want to
understand why that makes me angry and
when I speak on it I want the weight to
come from my conviction and my clarity
of thought and not from my body language
alone and you go back to that restaurant
you go back to that family member you go
back to that friend and you say hey
yesterday you did something you said
something that rubbed me the wrong way
and I've given that some thought and I
wanted to address that with you that has
a certain kind of gravity about it
that's so strong because you're
conveying to that person I care enough
to have put some thought into it and to
address this from a place that's not
rooted in impulse but that's rooted in
conviction that's how much I care and
that's an alternative to feeling like
well I just need to you know lash out at
the moment that you irritate me so the
wait for it rule applies to so much more
than just stuff it applies also to
conflict and relationships I in fact one
might argue it applies much more in
those scenarios yeah however
to add on to it don't wait too long for
it and I think that's the lesson of some
of the stuff we've been talking about
today because you wait too long oh I
really want to buy those shoes from
Amazon I'm gonna wait 30 years
yeah it's not going to come to fruition
but the same is true with conflict with
someone else I'll just wait till
tomorrow and if you keep waiting till
tomorrow again and again and again you
never make room for that conflict and
then baby Godzilla turns into adult
Godzilla and Godzilla is taking over the
city so wait for it but don't wait too
long for it yeah it's the lesson that
I've told myself
the fifth one that I have here Ryan
can you guess the no piles rule that's a
good one I like it or this uh set the
stage yes at the setting the stage rule
no piles rule we'll put links to both of
those in the show notes the fifth one
for me is
the emergency items rule oh yeah that's
an important one the emergency items
rule is like hey these are items
they're just in case items yeah I hope I
never have to use these yeah I hope I
never have to use this plunger but I own
one right because sometimes I'm full of
crap
and emergency items are just in case
items that I have on hand a uh chains
for tires if you're driving through the
snow in Montana or
um if I have a plunger at home or if I
have a first aid kit in my car jumper
cables which I didn't have any and Ryan
had to come out and give me a jump a few
weeks ago because I fell asleep in my
car and drive home and those it's an
emergency item I hope Ryan never has to
use them but I'm glad I'm sure glad that
he had them a few weeks ago right now
how does this apply outside of material
possessions right well I don't have just
in case friendships right but I do have
people that I can rely on
in case of an emergency amen and Ryan
you're definitely one of those people
you're you know you're the first call
you you have a collect call from the
Lebanon correctional institute it's
always from me every time I get arrested
I have his phone number memorized
I had like three phone numbers memorized
and yeah yours is definitely one of them
oh shoot I'll bail you out anytime buddy
I appreciate that yeah did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free